les agriculteurs du canada d'ailleurs
affirme que cette crise est dévastatrice
pour leurs activités ont rejoint tout de
suite marcel groleau président de
l'union des producteurs agricoles à
tahoua bonsoir monsieur gros lot
oui bonsoir général alors des groupes de
partout au canada
aujourd'hui d'un secteur agricole se
sont réunis ont tenu une conférence de
presse ont affirmé qu'il y a des effets
dévastateurs
lesquels en fait selon la région où on
habite au canada où l'on produit par
exemple les provinces centrales très
important pour eux de pouvoir expédier
leurs grains via le port de vancouver
actuellement on estime qu'une
cinquantaine de navires qui sont
stationnés dans les environs du port de
vancouver en attendant d'être chargé ces
navires le bon il ya des frais parce
qu'ils sont en attente il ya des frais
parce que les contrats sont pas
respectées il y avait des frais aussi
pour les prix sur les prix des céréales
qui actuellement sont à la baisse dans
ces secteurs là due à l'incapacité de du
transport des producteurs qui ont des
stocks actuellement de 2 g sur les rails
et dés de pomme ou d'autrui
chi chi perez ou dans les street dont
les acheteurs se tournent vers d'autres
marchés parce que faute d'être
approvisionné par ces ses livraisons là
qu'ils n'arrivent pas au québec ont
annoncé l'invs hertz
ici on atteint le propane on est aussi
inquiet sur l'approvisionnement de
certains ingrédients qui entrent dans la
fabrication des moules et alors ça
touche l'ensemble de l'agglo une pio
canadienne les réserves sont à combien
là au québec en travail au jour le jour
estimé s'est réservé la semaine dernière
on nous disait sept à 10 jours pour le
profane mais là on a eu des temps doux
qui ont permis qui vont permettre
d'allonger la période donc sa dette au
niveau du propane ça dépend beaucoup de
la température on est en discussion avec
le ministère des ressources naturelles
pour tenter d'évaluer les stocks puis
voir de quelle façon et c'est aux clubs
seront répartis
si l'approvisionnement des pauvres ne
fera pas au niveau du soya notamment
aussi ses tonnages
ça vient du beaucoup de l'ontario et
c'est là aussi on évalue les stocks au
jour le jour le pour s'assurer qu'on ne
manquent pas mais encore une fois c'est
difficile mais s'est adjugé au maquis
selon les informations que j'avais ya et
ça veut dire des pertes de combien ce
qu'on est capable de chiffrer déjà des
pertes les producteurs de l'ouest
estiment leurs pertes à 63 millions par
semaine due à l'incapacité de sortir
leurs grains ces pertes ne peuvent pas
augmenter
ici au québec les pertes ce au niveau
des prix plus élevés sur certains
ingrédients qu'on on a commencé à
constater
il n'y a pas eu de pertes au niveau de
la production animale au moment où on se
parle donc mais l'inquiétude levier bon
si jamais le blocus est levé et que le
transport reprend avant que la situation
revienne à la normale
on sait que c'est au moins dizaine de
jours le sait ce qu'on a vécu l'automne
dernier lorsqu'il ya eu la grève qui a
empêché bons clubs là qu'il transporte
des du cn alors c'est ce que six et dix
journées là s'ajoute une fois le blocus
levé la situation peut devenir plus
critique là dans les prochaines
prochains jours prochaines semaines
hélas les pertes pourraient être
beaucoup plus important se le dit
monsieur garneau aujourd'hui parle de
progrès que ça avance est ce que ça vous
encourage à naturellement oui mais ce
qu'on voit également c'est que plusieurs
mini bon jus mini blocage mais plusieurs
blocages qui se sont ajoutés et les gens
du cn travail
on est en contact avec eux aussi on
travaille à reprendre le service mais
doivent s'assurer que les lignes sont
sécuritaires et ça c'est sait pas encore
c'est pas encore le col alors pour
l'instant y'a pas de n'y a pas eu
d'amélioration par ailleurs on voit des
interventions policières pour libérer
des voix mais d'autres blocages
apparaissent çà vous souhaitez quoi vous
demandez quoi jusqu'où doit-on aller
selon vous c'est une question très
complexe parce que on règle va pas
deux cents ans d'histoire les
autochtones et entre les canadiens à
quelques semaines alors c'est sûr que ça
va prendre une collaboration de part et
d'autre du gouvernement et des gens qui
sont qui bloque les chemins de fer
aujourd'hui je l'espère à moi que les
gens vont être capables de s'asseoir et
de régler de façon régler autour d'une
table ces questions là plutôt que par le
blocage des chemins de fer alors ça
prend ça prend une collaboration des
deux parties nécessairement la ministre
marie claude bibeau s'est montrée prête
à rivaliser tout système de compensation
pour les blocages actuels les effets de
la météo la grève du chêne aussi
l'automne dernier vous vous attendez à
quoi de ce côté là c'est un peu des
engagements qui avaient été pris suite
aux conditions météo difficiles qu'on
avait eues la semaine l'année dans
l'automne dernier jusqu'à maintenant on
n'a pas vu des faits notables de ses
engagements à l'heure alors on n'est
plus couvert à discuter avec elle de
décompensation si les pertes s'avèrent
importants parce que les programmes
actuels la façon dont elle fonctionne
bon ils vont capter ces pertes que les
producteurs vont avoir mais ces pertes
clubs peuvent être dans les bilans
comptables des entreprises agricoles
quelquefois on les retrouve pas
nécessairement et lorsque les programmes
interviennent et interviennent sur les
bilans des entreprises alors ses pertes
les producteurs d assumer et puis ça
handicape les investissements à venir
dans les années futures donc si elle
veut s'asseoir avec nous puis vraiment
discuté de compensation n'est plus
couvert alpha et ça prend une ouverture
par contre à traiter les programmes
actuels de façon de faire et en
terminant entre temps est ce qu'il ya
des solutions pour vous des mesures de
rationnement qu'est ce qu'est ce que
vous suggérez vous proposer alors on
était en discussions avec le
gouvernement du québec pour ce qui est
de
l'approvisionnement en ingrédients pour
la fabrication des moules et alors on
suit ça de très près mais pour subvenir
à des besoins de certains producteurs
qui seraient en rupture de stock en on
demande aux producteurs de d'appeler à
l'union des producteurs agricoles ou
d'appeler au mapaq et on va travailler
avec eux pour trouver des solutions pour
les dépanner au moment où on se parle
c'est ce qu'on propose
oui mais si la crise durait vendent le
gouvernement devrait on a vérifié
d'autres moyens de transport transporté
par camion soit le propane ou les
ingrédients qui entrent dans la
fabrication des moules et c'est pas
possible le poids suffisamment de
camions pour remplacer le système
ferroviaire
ouais alors on pourrait pallier
temporairement des ad à des pénuries
sectorielle mais pas pour l'ensemble de
la province et ça c'est pas simple
effectivement merci le gros lot à ottawa
merci ça me fait plaisir merci beaucoup